make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay now some of you all
some of y'all have been over here like
Rob I really wish you would put what if
we now y'all know good and well that we
make up our what if stories on on
Saturdays on the watch lemon y'all
reaction brand-new right now what's
going on guys this is Rob and we are
covering what if Deadpool killed the DC
Universe oh this is gonna be a good one
you guys fun with these right like the
level what if stories are okay but like
there's just something just don't have
any imagination to them right but like
we can make ours up so like we can do
whatever we want we can we can give like
red lantern rings to like all the x-men
if we wanted to it's cool I think we
should do that you know what give us
give me ideas down in the in the
comments give me ideas for like what if
stories what I'm gonna let your
imaginations run wild
right like no limits just come up with
anything right like the spawn invades
the Marvel Universe like The Incredible
Hulk becomes spawn give me all kinds of
crazy ideas right give me just some
kooky stuff like I really want to know
what you guys come up with but yes so
the miniseries or at least this videos
based on the miniseries Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe and of course that
miniseries is a lot of you guys probably
know took place outside of the main
Marvel continuity and it told the story
of Deadpool being committed to the
Ravencroft Asylum against his will by
the x-men who basically hoped to cure
him of his insanity now if you want to
know about the whole story Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe Deadpool Killa
straighted and Deadpool kills Deadpool
which is all the Deadpool kills trilogy
check the description you'll find a link
to those videos down in the description
of this video so what is up happening is
that instead of Deadpool being cured
Deadpool basically comes to the
realization that he's a comic book
character and that basically they're
kind of in this cycle of being like
killed and being recreated by creators
and so on and so forth so he goes on a
crusade to quote-unquote save everyone
there's this amazing moment where you
take psycho man who was the guy that
manipulated him it starts like bashing
his head bashing his whole body and like
this is it's crazy but the funny thing
about this is that with psycho man's
plan backfiring basically Deadpool is
ultimately met with a third voice that's
represented by red text bubbles it
basically tells him to kill everybody in
the
and everybody in the Marvel Universe and
that's exactly what he does he kills the
x-men he kills the Fantastic Four he
kills the Avengers and literally all the
heroes and villains on earth now
eventually after he's killed everyone he
seeks out Man Thing who sacrifices
himself to give dead full access to the
Nexus of realities a gateway that allows
him to travel between all the realities
that exists so the Deadpool can achieve
his goal of killing all those who used
the Marvel heroes and villains as pawns
and so the next thing that we end up
seeing from Deadpool here is when he
enters the idea verse and Deadpool Killa
straited and basically see him murdering
characters from classical works of
literature like Moby Dick and Sherlock
Holmes but for our video today we're
gonna be taking a look at what would
happen if instead of going to the idea
first
Deadpool had turned up in the DC
Universe now when he arrives in the DC
Universe the first place that Deadpool
goes is the secret hideout of the Joker
as he wants to be the only sadist that
constantly makes jokes in the DC
Universe and also because he's tired of
Harley Quinn infringing on his gimmick
and of being the most overexposed
character in comics and he basically
explains that he knows this because not
only does he read DC Comics but he also
participates in online forms as after
all Deadpool is aware of the existence
of the fourth wall can see beyond it and
knows what the comic vine forms are
anyway once he gets there he mows down
Joker's henchmen with ease until only
Joker and Harley are left in his way
they donned gas masks and Joker releases
a plume of Joker toxin into Deadpool's
face and while it is initially effective
Deadpool's healing factor proves to be
too advanced for the toxin to have any
lasting effects and Joker and Harley
fall to Deadpool's blade relatively
quickly now after leaving the Joker's
hideout
Deadpool tells the new voices in his
head that now that Harley is out of the
way he can focus on hunting down the
biggest gimmick thief in the entirety of
the DC Universe a guy who's just a
complete ripoff of Deadpool himself he
dresses like Deadpool he's a mercenary
like Deadpool and not only is his
codename similar to Deadpool's but his
real name is almost identical to Wade
Wilson as well funny thing about it
Deadpool was based off this guy Deadpool
sets in search of Slade Wilson better
known as Deathstroke the voice in his
head tells him that many people think
Wade is actually the rip off as
Deathstroke has been around
significantly longer now Deadpool
remarks then it doesn't matter who
been around first that the guy who's
relegated as a side character on a TV
show on the CW will always be seen as a
knockoff version of the guy who starred
in two movies of his own which is true
so Deadpool is out tracking down
Deathstroke and they give us the battle
that fans have wanted to see for a long
time and they're actually very evenly
matched both are adept fighters with
strong healing factors although
Deadpool's healing factor is probably
the stronger of the two
at any rate they battle for a while in
Deathstroke remarked that they are bound
to fight forever as they can each just
keep healing from the damage inflicted
on them by the other and Deadpool
replies that this story is titled
Deadpool kills the DC Universe not
Deadpool comes to the DC Universe and
loses to Costco Brandenburg sped off
ending the battle now from there we see
Deadpool making his way throughout the
DC Universe and mowing down every hero
and villain that he comes across
characters like Nightwing Green Arrow
Blue Beetle Booster Gold and the birds
of prey all of Batman's rogues and many
others fall victim to Deadpool's rampage
now when he's finished wreaking havoc
Deadpool tells the voice in his head
that since he's cleared the DC Universe
of all of his b-list heroes it's time to
move on to the a-listers the Justice
League of America and as he sets off for
the Justice League Watchtower the voice
in his head asked how he plans to get
there since it's like you know an outer
space and Deadpool isn't well Deadpool
says not to worry he'll just walk off
the last panel of this page and then
when they get to the next page he'll be
there and that's exactly what happens
Deadpool shows up in the watchtower on
the next panel and the way I envisioned
this going down is that he's done his
research on what he needs to do to take
down DC's most iconic heroes by reading
about all their weaknesses in their
comics and as we'll get to in a minute
as powerful as these heroes are with the
exception of cyborg they have all had
some pretty ridiculous weaknesses over
the years and while most of these are no
longer canon we're in a what-if story
here so I think we can be a little fast
and loose with the continuity especially
for comedic effect and a storyline is
centred on Deadpool so Deadpool shows up
with all his knowledge that he's a mass
throughout reading comics as well as a
backpack full of stuff he's acquired on
his killing spree across the DC Universe
and so when he shows up and makes his
presence known to the Justice League
he's prepared for everything they're
going to be able to throw it in the
flash is the first to act
but Deadpool has a gun stolen from the
corpse of Captain cold that he blasts
the flash with slowing him down long
enough to throw a banana peel
in his path which causes the flash to
slip and fall headfirst into the tip of
Deadpool's sword impaling and killing
him instantly Wow Deadpool says honestly
I can't believe that actually worked I
thought maybe I was getting greedy going
with a banana peel but I have to admit
it wouldn't have nearly been awesome
without it now with that
martian manhunter moves to our Deadpool
who quickly drops his cold gun in favor
of a flame filler and Deadpool remarks
seriously dude your fire is weakness and
that's true it really is true right
Deadpool says it's not the dumbest
weakness any of you have but it has to
be the easiest to exploit and that's
true right like what is Martian
Manhunter really he's basically Superman
but he can he can shape-shift he has
telepathy and he's afraid of fire that's
it anybody who comes to you and says no
there's a lot more to the Martian
Manhunter than that they're lying to you
right like he's cool you know whatever
but he's just like oh no I could never
enjoy a fireplace you know but
regardless Deadpool points the muzzle of
the flamethrower toward Martian
Manhunter and lets loose a stream of
fire that engulfs and kills him and then
Deadpool of course says no as he turns
his attention to Hal Jordan the
distinction of dumbest weaknesses of all
time definitely goes to you yellow
seriously your weakness is a color and
not even an intimidating color but the
color of daffodils and sunshine and
fuzzy baby ducks I guess it could be
worse if you were vulnerable to
something really lame like I don't know
wood or something well then I guess were
particularly suck now Green Lantern's
ring produces a green light construct
that attempts to encase Deadpool with it
but Deadpool puts on a bright yellow
raincoat and house construct is unable
to affect him Deadpool then rummages
through his arsenal and grabs a wooden
spear painted bright yellow he hurls the
spear in Hal Jordan and the spear goes
straight through his heart and pins him
to the wall before he dies that actually
makes sense
hit the color yellow like how is he not
weak to sunshine that's my question
so that basically leaves Deadpool
standing face to face with the Trinity
of the DC Universe Superman Wonder Woman
and Batman now Batman steps forward and
roughly asked who Deadpool is and why
he's come to the watchtower and murdered
all of his friends and Deadpool looks at
Batman and softly says Bruce this won't
make sense but you have to believe me
Martha sent me
now Batman is stunned at the mention of
his late mother's name and tries to wrap
his mind around what the strange person
in a cheap destro Costner was told him
Deadpool uses this moment of trepidation
to draw his sword and slice off Batman's
head leaving Superman and Wonder Woman
in total shock
with their mouths gape at what just
happened to Batman now Deadpool asks
what he's just like a guy what did you
think was going to happen I don't have
to figure out his weakness because his
weakness is that his head comes off with
a sword when it passes through his neck
I do not get why you guys are so
surprised right now now in Reeves
Superman moves at SuperSpeed and lands a
devastating punch on Deadpool he's soon
joined by Wonder Woman and the last two
take turns pummeling Deadpool but of
course Deadpool just keeps healing from
the beatings now eventually Superman is
standing over Deadpool ready to deliver
what should be the final blow but he
hesitates not wanting to break his rule
against killing others no matter how
angry he is over the deaths of his
friends and Deadpool uses this opening
to draw a pistol from his side and fires
a single glowing green bullet in a
Superman's skull and the Man of Steel
staggers clearly weakened and Deadpool
unloads round after round of Kryptonite
bullets into Superman leaving him nearly
dead and suddenly suddenly Deadpool is
ensnared by Wonder Woman's lasso of
truth and she asked him who he is and
why he's here knowing that this time he
must tell her the truth he tells her his
name and says it he's there for
information and that once he gets it
he'll leave and spare her and Superman's
life he tells her that if she lets him
go and places the lasso on her own wrist
so that he knows she's telling him the
truth he'll leave and won't hurt anyone
else now normally she would never take
his word for this but she knows that
he's being truthful so she does as he
asked and puts the lasso on her arms and
allows him to take the other end which
he promptly pulls tight binding her
hands together and so the reason for
this is like I said there were some
ridiculous weaknesses these characters
had over the years and wonder woman's
weakness used to be that if her
bracelets were tied together by a man
she lost all of her power now obviously
this was eventually dropped as people
realized how dumb and sexist it was but
as I said we're ignoring a lot of
continuity as we're dealing with
alternate realities anyway by virtue of
this being a what-if story but
regardless Wonder Woman is shocked that
Deadpool was able to lie to her while
being ensnared by the last
when he explains that since he's not
from her reality the lasso has no effect
on him and since she's now powerless
he's able to simply just kill her before
doing the same to Superman by unloading
a few more rounds of kryptonite bullets
into him before he dies and so following
this deadpool makes his way back to
earth having slain the mightiest of DC
heroes and heads back towards the nexus
of all realities when the voice in his
head asks him where he's gonna go next
and he replies I don't know Mordor
Hogwarts Tatooine Disney World who can
say and with that he steps inside the
Nexus leaving a defeated universe behind
him so yeah that's kind of how I see
that going down I think it's awesome I
think it's a cool story I kind of feel
like we should expand on that Deadpool
vs. the Sinestro Corps or like the Red
Lanterns okay here's my question for you
guys which Lantern Corps would Deadpool
end up joining that's my question like
which which Lantern ring would Deadpool
get what's being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
first I want to say thank you to all of
the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explained I
want to give a shout out to Henry young
- Elias G David J s Jacob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like lu-david C John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Cage enosis 916 I want to say
thank you to all of you all this list is
growing all the time
leave it to the patreon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you